bonjour je m'appelle ellis du times qui
j'ai 23 ans et j'habite à
montigny-le-bretonneux dans les yvelines
je suis préparatrice en pharmacie de
formation et j'ai également un bts
management des unités commerciales
donc mon projet aujourd'hui c'est
d'ouvrir un institut de soins de la peau
dans les divines de préférence
[Musique]
je suis accompagné de mon associé qui se
nomme émail ou non on aimerait proposer
de nombreux soins de la peau grâce à une
nouvelle technologie qui vient
directement des états unis et qui se
nomme hydra faciale notre nouvelle
technologie consiste à nettoyer en
profondeur la peau et à la reid rester
sur du long terme
[Musique]
pendant la période de covin avec mon
associé ont remarqué que les femmes
avaient du mal à trouver leur routine
adaptée à leur type de peau ils
n'étaient pas toujours satisfaite du
coup on a souhaité trouver une idée ou
une nouvelle technologie pour justement
répondre aux besoins de notre clientèle
c'est un peu d'excitation le ce
challenge j'aime / surmonter mes
objectifs du coup
c'était ça mon objectif travailler pour
soi aussi
[Musique]
les déterminés nous ont permis d'étudier
l'étude de marché de cibler notre
clientèle est également de créer notre
business plan idéal ce qui nous manque
aujourd'hui pour notre projet c'est
d'être accompagnés sur tout ce qui est
statut juridique sur les locaux et
également sur les plans de financement
[Musique]
on a 12 nombreux objectifs tout d'abord
respecter l'ouverture de mme et 2022
puis par la suite fidéliser notre
clientèle et faire notre clientèle et
notre objectif sur du long terme ce
serait également d'ouvrir un second
institut dans le sud de la france